you know i'm quite glad i came out on
this channel
about three years ago now back when i
was only 10
000 subscribers as opposed to getting
any significantly bigger than that
and dealing with the blowback of having
a larger audience
and then coming out and that's not
really speculation on my part
every now and then i'll get a comment
from somebody who basically says the
equivalent of
i haven't seen you in years my god what
happened to you i won't watch anymore
[Music]
so what was the point of that little
anecdote well
it has to do with the main topic that i
want to talk about today
which is something that i see a little
bit less than i used to but i still see
it
and i feel like it's one of those things
that has been
in the back of my mind to do as a
general topic
for a while when it comes to issues of
representation
and that is the idea and there's
actually two sides of this coin
and it has to do with people who are
already extremely well represented
cis straight white header of men let's i
mean let's just get that out there
primarily
who see more diverse casts
or diverse main characters or heroes or
gay relationships and say some equal
equivalent of you're alienating your
fans
i'm not going to watch this i can't
relate to that
or the flip side of that
telling minority people why
do you need something specifically
pandering to you
a good character is relatable to anybody
why can't you just
be happy with the media that's out there
if it's good
which as i said two sides of the same
coin and both rooted in the same
core issues which is basically tunnel
vision
this is something that i actually have
not a completely unique but you know i
have a little bit more insight
into this than uh sometimes happens when
i talk about
representation in people's perceptions
of it
because for a
substantive portion of my life
i identified
as a straight white
heterosexual
cisgender
man
oh god i'm sorry
i'm not laughing at someone being that
it's just the idea that i used to think
i was that it's
i find that amusing
but as time has gone on and especially
over the last
oh probably about five years or so
as i've really come to embrace and kind
of evolve
into my gender fluidity and
be just more myself in my presentations
and my mannerisms and not
worry about how it looks
i have found that i
have a harder time relating
to the kinds of media that i used to
relate to previously
because i used to or at least my
perception of myself
used to much more directly correlate
with the main characters in a lot of
films in television
whereas now they don't so much
but i don't have to imagine
quite as much that mindset
because at least partially
i can work off memory
and to a certain degree
these positions understandable
and i do kind of get it because
if you've never wanted for
representation
if key parts of your sense of self
like your race your gender
your sexuality if
those are frequently depicted
then you honestly do not know what it
feels like
to not have that and the thing is
even when a piece of media comes out
that has far fewer or maybe doesn't have
it all or maybe
only the bad guys and the and people
were meant to laugh at or the
straight cis white men or whatever even
when that comes out
and if you feel distanced from that
it's still not the same and honestly
a lot of people who are underrepresented
for whatever reason aren't really going
to be able to understand how it is you
feel if you feel it alienated by more
diverse media
and the reason that they won't
understand
is because for them and for me
also at this point
we are used to having to
find aspects of ourselves in people that
in no way were built to represent
us in core elements of who we are
it's been tackled by some other people
across this platform
but there is a reason that a lot of
lgbtq plus people gravitate towards
monster characters or
something like the x-men not originally
explicitly written to be an analog
for us but we find a way to project
ourselves into that and
we're used to having to do that
because for most of us it's something
we've had to do our whole lives in my
case
maybe not my entire life but from
starting to come into my own as
initially a cross-dresser it's something
i've been doing for
almost 20 years so
it's something that we have
to a certain degree acclimated to and
that doesn't mean that we don't
appreciate it when we get
actual legitimate representation but it
does mean that
we're used to just dealing with it
we're used to finding other things to
latch on to
because these main core key elements of
who we are are not reflected back onto
us
and if you are excessively represented
in media
honestly you don't have that skill you
haven't had
years of having to project yourself in
and find other ways to connect to
characters you don't
have that muscle memory
for lack of a better term you haven't
worked
that part of your empathy enough
you're not used to doing it so it feels
like more work it feels harder
and it can feel like more of an affront
when you can't connect to something
because you're used to being able to
if it's intended for a mass audience now
while to a certain extent i may have
just validated that feeling
i need to stress something very hard and
i've said this before
i am not going to hold you responsible
for your feelings
and for your gut reaction to things
because
honestly you are not going to have a lot
of control over that
the ability to control your initial gut
level reaction
first of all you have to recognize what
it is that you are feeling and why and
then work really hard on that it's going
to take a long time to get over that
and it's a lot of work it's work often
worth doing
if you realize the reason for your gut
reaction is something that
is uninformed or misguided or just
destructive but
that does still take a lot of work and
i'm not going to judge you for your
feeling
of i can't relate to this
i am however going to judge you on what
you do with that feeling
not responsible for your first gut
instinct
you are responsible for your behavior
based on that first gut instinct though
and when your reaction
to other people being represented
is to shout that it shouldn't be here
by whatever justification you care to
throw over that
whether you try to justify it as
unrealistic
that a character is something other than
white
or other than male or pandering
or propaganda or pushing an agenda
however you wish to dress it up if
you're yelling at the very presence of
people who do not get to see themselves
in mainstream media
just don't
because you are experiencing
and need to learn how to grapple with
and work that muscle
and get it better the need
to empathize
to find a way to connect with characters
and stories that do not speak directly
to your own experiences
and honestly that is a good skill to
have
for everybody it's
vital and if it's underdeveloped and
you're not willing to nourish it
well you're just going to keep lashing
out
because you feel left out and again
i do actually get why but that doesn't
make it okay
to shout at the presence
of diverse characters it doesn't make it
okay
to shout at the presence of diverse fans
it doesn't make it okay to demand
that you be pandered to
because that's the thing if you're going
to make the argument
that inserting
people of color queer characters
with disabilities fat people
if you are going to argue that
their presence is pandering to some
audience
then you need to prepare to admit to the
fact that
if what you have is a bunch of
heterosexual cisgender
fit white men then
that's pandering to an audience
you don't get to call only one type of
casting pandering
and then pretend like if it's something
that appeals to you well that's not
pandering
no that's that's that's as it should be
no
it's either all pandering or none of it
is
so you need to be honest are you mad
that
there's pandering happening at all are
you just mad that you aren't the one
being pandered to
and maybe you feel a little less special
you feel a little less acknowledged
a little less seen
like maybe the people who made it aren't
considering you
well if you're feeling that then you are
getting a
tiny sliver of a glimpse
of what people who do not have
representation
and don't get to see themselves in media
especially mainstream media intended for
mass consumption
you're getting the slightest taste of
what that's like
it's an opportunity for empathy to take
that feeling that gut feeling of oh
examine it question it
think about why it's there think about
whether it's helpful
whether it's constructive
whether there's anything you can do to
change it
uh because you're still going to be
pandered to by plenty of media
i mean it was 20 somewhat entries into
the marvel cinematic universe before we
had our first
female lead black lead
weird i'm still waiting i gotta wait for
the eternals before we get a
queer character who's gonna have a name
and has superpowers
you are plenty pandered too
don't get mad and shout down people
for getting a sliver of a pie
just because you're used to having the
whole thing and look
like i said i'm not going to judge you
your gut instinct
i've had stuff i've had to get over i've
had stuff that i've had to examine
still do i'm not a perfect person
i've had gut reactions to things that
i've looked at
with a more discerning eye and gone oh i
gotta work on that
and i try to and i'll always have work
to do
we all do and that's okay
and if you can't relate to something
that speaks to people who aren't you
well maybe think about why
i'm not saying you have to find a way to
relate to it
but maybe try and if you still can't
okay fair enough you still have no
business shouting people down
for wanting representation
or for actually finally having it
so that's it folks this is another one
that i'm just like i
nothing specifically set this off but
it's just one of those things that's
been perking in the back of my mind for
long enough i'm like let's let's
let's get my thoughts on this on the
record
what do you think about anything that
i've said today whatever your thoughts
are
i hope you'll drop something down the
comments and we'll talk about it i have
a patreon
which is how this channel is supported
and is in fact how i pay my bills
and make my living there are rewards for
every tier
from getting to see the docket of what
i'm gonna do in the upcoming month to a
discord to your name and the credits
you'll be seeing those shortly
but if you're not able to do that
there's also youtube memberships those
help me out as well
even if you can't do that the likes the
shares subscribes the
hit the bell thing yeah that's still
there
do that or don't it's okay
i'm not gonna tell you what you have to
do
because at the end of the day you're the
council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time
as council's adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
you